direction Sainte-Suzanne objectif la
cascade Niagara c'est là via ferrata de
la Réunion un parcours acrobatique en
falaise sur fond de cascade tonitruantes
avec pour ajouter du piment à
l'itinéraire un pont népalais à 60
mètres au-dessus du bassin et une
tyrolienne de 70 mètres pour finir en
beauté c'est beau c'est fun et
accessible à tous même si on la surnomme
la randonnée du vertige c'est une bonne
occasion de s'initier à l'escalade avec
Gérard damour
le parcours aventure de Niagara donc la
cascade Niagara afin de Suzanne
se compose de différents ateliers nous
avons donc démonté d'échelle des
traversées de filets dépôt un pont
népalais et le parcours se termine par
une tyrolienne
petite spécificité du parcours aventure
de la cascade Niagara c'est vraiment ce
pont n'est pas les qu'on voit déjà dès
le parking cette série de câbles qui
traverse la rivière au dessus de la
cascade donc c'est un câble sur lequel
on va marcher avec deux câbles de chaque
côté pour la main droite pour la main
gauche et puis un quatrième câble qui
lui va concerner la sécurité sur
l'évolution sur le sur ce fameux pont
népalais qui donne un peu de sensation
voir beaucoup de hauteur et qui offre
vraiment une vue imprenable sur la
marine
Sainte-Suzanne et aussi l'amour de la
rivière
la progression sur le parcours aventure
est très simple ça s'assimule beaucoup à
une échelle nous avons des barreaux que
nous avons installé tout au long du
parcours pour permettre justement une
progression aisée facile ce qui donne
une très bonne approche on va dire de
l'escalade et ma chaîne
a commencé on va dire en Italie et c'est
exporter un petit peu partout c'est un
sport qui est assez en vogue et celle
qu'on rencontre à la cascade Niagara est
à l'heure actuelle la seule sur la
Réunion donc c'est la seule vraie
randonnée verticale qu'on va retrouver
donc accessible à tous pourquoi le site
de Niagara parce que c'est un site
simple accessible et pourvu d'une
falaise avec du vrai caillou bien dur
avec du vrai rocher dans un cadre quand
même magnifique
la falaise de la cascade Niagara est
aussi à côté du pique-nique quand même
un lieu historique de l'escalade à la
Réunion c'est l'une des premières
falaises qui a été équipée ça va pour en
cotation au terme un peu technique du 5c
4 du 4 on va dire jusqu'à 6 et 7 ans à
peu près
il a fallu à peu près 6 mois pour
exécuter l'ensemble de l'installation
avec de beaux moyens techniques
notamment des nous avons des bars qui
rentrent à plus de 2 mètres ou entre
deux et quatre mètres dans la falaise
donc ce qui permet de retenir le câble
qui est on va dire toute la sécurité du
parcours
de manière solide et vraiment ancrée
quoi